tu crois que tu es une adulte que tu es
une femme alors agi comme une femme
tu as une nouvelle famille d'accueil je
m'en fous dès que mon père sort de taule
j'irai chez lui tu vois pas que je bosse
pourquoi t'es pas venu me voir j'étais
occupée
on en a déjà parlé mais il n'est plus
temps tuteur légal
plus maintenant
tu as dit que je voulais pas que tu
traînes par ici c'est mon chemin pour
aller m'entraîner si tu veux tout savoir
jamais entendu parler d'une fille qui se
bat dans l'équipe des mec t'as qu'à
venir voir
[Musique]
allez au suivant en suivant tibet
il va y avoir du nouveau dans l'équipe à
2,3 les gagnants n'abandonne jamais ses
mots
ta mère est morte j'ai fait ce que je
devais faire j'avais pas le choix
t'imagines si on va vraiment en finale
je te maries que tu vas avoir une bourse
d'études
écoute tu vas devenir une légende et ce
qui est sûr ce ne sera pas que dans les
annuaires d'école alors regarde ses
filles et apprend
[Applaudissements]
ses potes écoutez moi les gars
souvenez-vous perdre est quelque chose
qui n'existe pas on peut uniquement
gagner et à prendre ses rêves ou la main
mais qu'est ce que tu fais tu vas me
dire ce qui s'est passé avec ton père
c'est moi qui te fier de qui je suis ton
assistante sociale et si je ne peux pas
dire confiance je ne peux pas t'aider
mais je sais pas où est l'argent
[ __ ] voter coûte rien alors toi de la
grèce progressent
[ __ ] mais qu'est ce que tu fous mort
voici le moi est ce que vous les coûts
maintenant tu marches tu crèves à toi de
voir
[Musique]